[Music]
if you are picking a brain and one
listens to everything you try to do
works according to plans sticks the
schedules is obedient and calm and the
second is a hellscape of chaos and
obsession lacks all sense of structure
organization just love staying up until
3am overthinking every night
i mean you'd pick the first one right
everything seems to be built for type 1
brains in a world full of success
stories based on consistency atomic
habits and self-disciplined routine it
can seem impossible to succeed without
just that and so for the longest time
all i've wanted was a different brain
one that would actually listen to me
because as someone who has never been
able to create any sense of long-term
structure if you can relate to me at all
here is how i think we can end up right
where our consistent habit-forming
friends are without ever needing to be
consistent or create habits because even
though on the outside i realize it looks
as though i'm an organized person i run
this youtube channel by myself i have a
podcast and jobs and school but the
thing is on the inside it's probably not
what you think it is so let's just get
straight into it i'm going to start my
case against consistency and habit
formation using my younger self as an
example because i feel that she had a
much better grasp on how to organize
myself so i'm going to get a slight
cringe pass here but when i was younger
i was very good academically at the end
of the year i would always have the best
grades i would win olympiads i would get
all types of reward for excellent
academic achievement so you would
presumably think that i was a very
organized and well put together student
and this is not the case on any given
day of the year if you were to zoom in
chances are i had forgotten what
subjects i had that day i might have
left my homework at home or had never
done my homework because i'd forgotten
to do it or sometimes very cheekily i
just didn't want to do it and so i very
often kind of fell behind during the
year but this was completely normal to
me i always recognized that sometimes i
didn't feel like doing something so i
fell behind and then i got interested in
it so i caught up and then i got very
interested in it so i went ahead and
this fall behind catch up and go ahead
schedule was very natural to me very
often on the same day that i was behind
on something that night i would study
the next three months of that subject
that we hadn't even done yet so i would
go ahead everyone else i was just using
my passion when i wanted to do things
and one of the most important things i'd
had to reteach myself as an adult is
that falling behind is not quitting it's
just a third of the story because i feel
as though when i got older and i got
used to seeing everyone being super
consistent and having these habits as
soon as i didn't do something for a
while i thought that i had quit and that
i'm just not as good as everyone else at
this thing and it's not right for me
when this is not the full story being a
chaos and passion driven person falling
behind is just a third of the story
sometimes i don't do things but it's
guaranteed that if i genuinely want to
do them i will catch up and go ahead
much later and this has been such an
important thing for me to relearn i
generally believe that consistency is
not for everyone and those of us who
cannot adapt it end up quitting so many
things just because we think that we
can't be consistent and therefore we
cannot do it i know it's not the best
thing in the world but sometimes i go to
gym five times a week for a few months
in a row and sometimes i won't go to the
gym at all for five months but i know
that this doesn't mean that i hate
exercising because i'm going to want to
do it again and i'm going to catch up on
the progress that i missed out on during
that time when i genuinely didn't feel
like doing it just because i stopped
does not mean that i have quit something
forever douglas adams has a quote that i
really relate to when he says that i
love deadlines i love the wishing noise
they make as they go by and this is so
relatable for me any sort of artificial
deadlines are just not serious enough
for me to use and therefore even though
that i know that there are some harsh
deadlines in life for example when i was
younger i had end of your exams now as
an adult i need to hand projects in i
have other things that i need to do for
work but in between now and then i do
not create any real deadlines anything
that i put in my calendar is a
suggestion it's not something that i
need to do it's more like if i feel like
it i might do this today but just
because i skip it one two three four
five six times in a row does that mean
that i cannot catch up on this thing
later or that i'm not good at this thing
at all i only treat real deadlines like
deadlines all the arbitrary ones are
suggestions and i don't create any sort
of self-hate or hatred for the thing
that i'm doing around them now i'm very
comfortable never being a consistent
habit farming girl but always being a
full-behind catch-up and go ahead girl
because just like it used to do well for
me academically when i was younger it
honestly does really well for me in life
right now because it's just the way i
work and this leads me very comfortably
onto what's perhaps a very controversial
point which is screw one percent
improvements i love james clear his book
atomic habits is really really good but
it genuinely has caused me a lot of
damage because when i saw his one
percent improvement graphs which is
basically the thought that if you keep
improving at something just one percent
every single day by the end of the year
you will be exponentially better at this
thing which is really really true it's a
hundred percent true so i looked at this
graph and my heart just sank because i
realized i could never do this i could
never do something consistently for a
year because the best way to get me to
hate something or to quit something is
to make a strict schedule for it if you
tell me elizabeth you need to do this
thing three times a week for the next
two months there's no chance i'm just
going to leave it and so i realized that
it's never going to work because one
percent improvements only work if you do
things very consistently if you do
things three times a month and you
improve one percent every time you're
getting absolutely nowhere and even
worse if you do things twice a year and
you improve only one percent at them
that's no improvement you're going to
stop doing these things because as
frederick hesburgh in the harvard
business review identified something
that we probably all know intuitively of
all forms of human motivation the most
effective one is progress which
basically means the better we get at
something the more we want to do it and
this one percent improvements only works
if you're consistent and so i'm stuck in
this conundrum where i have to be
consistent in order to improve and so i
can never improve or want to do
everything and i'm always stuck with low
level motivation for everything in my
life this is where my method comes in
basically what i've decided is to
completely screw the one percent
improvement and go for five percent 500
5000 improvements every single time and
genuinely this is how i've learned my
skills this is how i've learned to draw
to paint to edit and everything so i'm
going to explain how i do this
specifically if you are also a chaotic
passionate person hopefully this might
work for you a few years ago i wanted to
learn 3d animation because i saw people
who create the video game characters and
stuff and i thought oh my god this looks
so cool i want to learn how to do it the
way to quit this for me is to go okay so
twice a week for the next six months i'm
going to slowly learn how to 3d anime no
no this would never work what i do
instead is that i do nothing but i just
passively kind of look at animations
here and there so whenever i'm
procrastinating or i have some free time
i'll just go through my phone and i'll
look at really good 3d animated work and
what i'm doing here is that i'm
passively priming my brain to get
passionate about this thing and to fall
in love with this thing and i'm not
allowing myself to start the work
because i'm just doing this thing slowly
and slowly and slowly and at some points
i'll reach a tipping point while i go
straight i need to learn this right now
because i can't wait to learn this so
then i'll just sit down and honestly i
had never done any work before in my
life i sat down and i sat for maybe 10
to 15 hours on my laptop and i taught
myself from nothing to be basically
quite good at learning to animate and
then on the second day i created this
and i'll show it on screen on the third
day i was really good i created this so
in three days i learned something that
admittedly i could have pieced myself
and done for a very long time if i was
different i just can't do things that
way so i went for like 10 000
improvements basically in the space of
three days which otherwise i would have
never been able to achieve because if i
would have tried to get to one percent
improvement i would have quit very very
early on so this is how i learn skills
without creating habits i prime myself
for extreme passion and then i get to do
them and also another huge benefit of
this is that you get to learn things so
much faster and with so much more focus
because as much as i envy and i'm so
jealous of consistent and organized
people because they can do so many
things the one thing that i think i'm a
lot better at is deep work i don't
understand why people struggle with deep
work i'm always falling into deep work
and i think it's because they pace
themselves too much and they create
these short schedules or i'm only going
to do this for 40 minutes a day if you
sit into it if you get in the proper
mood to want to do something properly
you can get extreme levels of focus and
therefore crazy results and because for
my personal projects and things that i
want to work on i only work in a deep
work state i can get so much more done
and learn a lot faster and therefore i'm
leveraging huge amounts of passion huge
amounts of focus the best kind of state
of mind for learning to get extreme
results really really fast without one
percent improvements so yeah this is how
i hack my brain into learning things now
i'm pretty sure a lot of you might be
thinking this really doesn't work for
everything and you would be 100 right i
think the toughest pill for me to
swallow especially as a competitive
person is the realization that there are
certain things in life that i will just
never be good at i know this is hard to
say for me but it's it's just true i
will never be good at memorizing facts
because you need to repeat things again
and again in order to remember them
consistently it's not for me i love
exercise but i will never be a
bodybuilder because it takes ridiculous
amounts of food restriction and exercise
for a long amount of time to get
somewhere and i can absolutely never do
that but this doesn't mean that i can't
learn some things or that i can't enjoy
exercise so i think that in my life i do
not optimize for consistency i optimize
for passion because even though there
are some things that i'm always going to
be really bad at there are some things
that i'm always very very good at i can
get inhumane amounts of work done in a
short burst of time i can learn huge
amounts of information in short periods
of time and also i have a very creative
bigger picture mind because i touch
things intensively and then i leave them
for a very long time so when i come back
to them i can see things differently so
i am very good at bigger picture
thinking so if you're also kind of a
chaotically passionate person you might
be the same as me and we're better at
these things than we are at strict
scheduled routines so when it comes to
both personal projects and as much as i
can in my professional life and things i
have less control over i tend to
optimize for being a passionate person
because that's where i can shine there's
this very interesting study that showed
that 50 of the amount of work done in a
company is done by the top 10 of workers
and also the best performer is a hundred
times more productive than the lowest
performer in the company and this
doesn't mean that we should all aim to
be the most productive person but
basically what that means is that these
people who are at the top are probably
having a lot more fun and also just in
their natural element so i think
recognizing my strengths recognizing the
things that i'm good at and optimizing
for those as much as i can leads to
better results in my life and also just
letting go of the things that are just
too painful and impossible for me to do
because trust me i've tried and it does
not work as a slight caveat here of
course i do not mean that i lead my life
just based on my feelings and passions
and some level of strictness and
rigorousness and routine is absolutely
necessary to function in the world
especially with meetings and jobs so i
can do these things i'm just not the
best at them and so even though there's
these strict schedules when it comes to
the work that i need to do on my own
which realistically is a huge amount of
work on any job i'm a lot less strict
and a lot less rigorous and a lot more
passion driven my next very important
point is having adult and not childish
and bratty conversations with myself
because very often i can be a childish
brat in my mind and what i mean by this
is that if i have something to do and i
don't do it i can be very annoying if
you asked a child why they didn't do a
task and they told you i'm just a lazy
person and i didn't do it you wouldn't
accept that answer would you you'd
probably go okay honey you that might be
true but what did you do instead and why
did you feel that you wanted to do that
more what would have made this task more
interesting for you when do you think
you might want to do it and most
importantly why do you think you need to
do this in the first place i think it's
so underrated exploring why we need to
do things because you're not an idiot
you can't just tell yourself to do
something and then you're going to do it
i think it's very important to explore
why we make choices in the first place
when we can and when we don't have a
trace and we have to do things anyway
kind of exploring why this is important
and why things function this way might
make it much more likely for us to
actually go through with the task so
when it comes to conversations with
myself i cut myself off when i go i'm
just a procrastinator oh i'm so lazy oh
i just didn't want to do it and rather
go a level deeper and say what needs was
i trying to fulfill because it's
unlikely that i have a need to browse
instagram and much more likely have a
need to rest or have a need to have fun
or have a need to connect with people
and i can see how i can fulfill these
needs more productively in other ways or
i can see how i can turn the task that i
have to do and don't want to do into
something that might increase the
likelihood of me kind of fulfilling
these needs for connection and enjoyment
and rest and everything else so more
adult conversations with ourselves i
think are much more important in order
to kind of work with the chaos in our
mind on the topic of priming my brain to
get passionate to learn things what i'm
currently trying to get ready to learn
is to be better at animation
specifically for youtube videos and i'm
using philip demiko's class on this on
nebula which are very kindly sponsoring
this video it's quite embarrassing that
i didn't know this as a nebula user but
there are now full-on classes on nebula
where you can genuinely have
professional creators teach you things
which is completely crazy if you're
currently already a nebular user it's
just a five dollar upgrade but the
classes are absolutely insane production
venue and i'm lowkey getting tempted to
create one of my own if you have any
ideas by the way for a class for me to
make please let me know because um yeah
they look super super cool if you want
to upgrade any of your skills there are
some classes from some of my favorite
youtubers on there already so there'll
be a link in my description if you
wanted to check that out but otherwise
if you made it so far here is to endless
organized chaos i hope you have a
wonderful rest of your day be honest
yourself and others and don't believe
everything you think thanks bye